hey everyone I'm Brian Cantrell I'm the
CTO of the oxide computer company
I'm a little worried because John
masters who is a friend of mine from
wave Red Hat now at new via I tweeted
out a reference to this talk and he he
only included the title kind of up until
the :
Brian's gonna talk on the soul of a new
machine and I would say a decent amount
of the internet believed that I am
leading a book club discussion of Tracy
Kidder's superlative the soul of a new
machine I'm not so if I'm happy to talk
about the soul of a new machine I love
it it's an amazing book if you haven't
read it
it is truly it is it is the the Iliad or
the Odyssey it is the literature of our
domain but I'm only using it as a title
so no disrespect to cater um but what I
really want to speak of is really kind
of tap into some of that that same
fervor and passion and depth that that
kid are described in for those of you
don't know Sullivan a machine describes
the development of the the data general
eclipse couldn't eagle in the late 70s
and early 80's and it was it was kind of
it was a time when any of people asked
me if I romanticized you know the 70s or
the 80s or the 90s um and maybe a little
bit you know maybe maybe maybe a tiny
bit um I don't think I overly
romanticized them um but this is I would
call that the first real server because
this is the first machine that is really
powerful enough and um you know the 709
is is an amazing machine it is it is the
first machine that is is really powerful
enough to actually have a time shared
workload on it and this is the this is
the last of the of the vacuum to vacuum
tube machines obviously machine this is
look at the control planner from the 7
or 9 this is not the actual 709 itself
um
the this the actual 709 itself is quite
a bit larger than this I'm quite a bit
less beautiful this is actually from the
there was a terrific series of surveys
done in the the kind of the dawn of
computing of effectively all computers
in the US
and this is probably the this is the
last year I could have been reasonably
done but this is the the 709 that was at
Hughes there were a bunch of 709 I just
I call this one out because the the the
dimensions are something else for a
computer and this is one of the things
that that it's easy to forget and kind
of the post transistorized age vacuum
tubes have a lot of drawers there's not
the transistor is a really good idea
vacuum tubes are pretty power intensive
205 kW for the IBM 709 which is so - as
a reminder like a rack draws somewhere
between if between 10 and 25 kW for a
rack today that is 205 kilowatts in 1961
for a machine that is 33,000 pounds it
is 1,900 square feet I love the fact
that the machine is 2,000 square feet
and the air conditioner is another
thousand square feet so this is a
fire-breathing monster although it
wasn't really a monster I mean it was
really tepid from a sizing perspective
but it was the first machine that was
big enough and the reason it's important
is because it is the first server and it
in that it is the first machine that is
large enough to actually run a time
shared workload and indeed the
compatible time sharing system CDSs was
originally done on demonstrated on the
IBM 77 or 9 in the early sixties so the
server-side computing is born what I
mean by server-side computing I mean a
computer that you don't necessarily hold
in your hands you don't have in front of
you you don't necessarily see or hear or
smell it is running your workload at
some kind of a distance um you know fast
forward through third through the 70s um
you know if you are of a certain vintage
this is certainly Mother's Milk to you
this is the the pdp-11 70 this is the if
the the 709 was the the kind of the dawn
of the mainframe kind of kind of I've
cut out the 360 I would happily talk
about historical machines the entire
time I cut out the 360 obviously very
important machine but the pdp-11 70 is
certainly an interesting machine in many
different dimensions this is now a
scaled-down machine and one where you
can run workloads
much more locally than you could with
with a mainframe a very very important
machine actually when my co-founders has
gone a replica of this machine in her in
her house which is pretty great running
a Raspberry Pi blinking the lights which
is pretty neat but uh it and with the
kind of the mini computer revolution in
in the 70s
these machines were getting smaller yes
that is a good question that's a that's
a good one to register I actually don't
know I do know from having messed around
with the JavaScript emulator of the
pdp-11 70 that there are a lot to choose
from so uh the the you should be right
you should be running tops-10 tops-20 I
think ran on the PDP 1170
no it didn't all right Brennan does it
see the sign nine
she certainly UNIX ran on the PDP 1170 I
don't think she's running a faux blown
UNIX girl anyway um important system ran
a bunch of different operating systems
obviously on the and a seminal machine
machine that definitely
outperformed from a deck perspective for
sure they expected to make ten thousand
of these and they made one hundred
thousand-plus really made the company um
then we get to so that you know this may
be Mother's Milk for many of you in the
room many people online this is Mother's
Milk for me so I worked for some
fourteen years this is the the son a 10k
I love the fact that this is this photo
is even taken from a vantage point to
make this machine look as imposing as
possible on this is a machine with 64
CPUs
64 gigabytes of memory and this is a
machine that essentially 1999 um you
know I I feel like as a survivor of the
dot-com bust I feel it's my
responsibility to younger generations to
explain that you actually are not in a
recession proof industry this box in
particular ran a good chunk of the
internet a lot of a lot of websites ran
on this sometimes infamously eBay
started off on a two processor machine
ended up with one of these 64 processor
giants and because they didn't revisit
their architecture along the way hadn't
bother to make or they could take the
Machine down excuse me um for any kind
of maintenance at all so of course they
were they were operating under a death
warrant that was signed that they didn't
quite realize and eBay very famously
went down in 1997 running one of these
machines in a disaster of absolutely
biblical proportions down for 22 hours
but it was it was eye-opening in a lot
of ways it was eye-opening because of
how important server-side computing had
become that we were now actually running
commerce on a single machine running
commerce with the server-side computers
that we had actually not really designed
with uptime in mind suddenly became very
load-bearing with respect to this new
economy and it was very very eye-opening
but so what what happened from 1999 and
from the kind of the you had a couple of
very keep your company's excuse me keep
your economies making very large
machines and what what happened is a
microprocessor and this was the spark
microprocessor which you know sadly the
the children today it's not necessarily
heard of because spark and every other
risk microprocessor effectively lost the
plot to to Intel x86 and what happened
was that the the the microprocessor in
here and in power machines and in PNP
risk based machines and in alpha
machines could no longer compete with
the economics of the x86 and what people
began to realize is like actually I can
get you this a 64 processor machine but
I can have a workload that runs maybe
maybe with a quarter of the number of
CPUs it's maybe a maybe a tenth but I
can do that for a twentieth of the cost
or one one-hundredth of the cost um and
that effectively um that revolution the
microprocessor revolution extinguished
these large servers and we ended up with
this um we went from from this in 1999
as the state of the art in server-side
computing I think I'm gonna need some
water by the way um to my iPod is much
drier down here that it is an in San
Francisco um the two
um to this in in 2009 and uh this is sad
in a lot of ways um so um and I don't
mean to pick on it this is an important
machine this is the HP dl380 I think
this is a Gen 5 dl380 the dl380 became a
ubiquitous machine again x86 at its core
but the reason this is sad is because
this is a this is a server thank you all
right this is a server but you notice
there's I there's a CD tray in front
it's like what is it what does a CD tray
I mean we were going to be playing music
in the datacenter why do we have a why
do we have a CD tray in here and what is
the display port that's a VGA port
sitting over there uh what is that thing
for and the answer is that this is
actually despite it being rack-mounted
this is a personal computer
this is architectural a personal
computer architectural II this is the
machine talked about you talk to the
pdp-11 70s as outperforming expectations
the IBM PC really outperformed
expectations right and the IBM PC was
really designed to be you know IBM's
entree into what seemed to be a very
hobbyist market they thought they're
gonna sell 10,000 of them obviously sell
millions and millions of them and the
architectural decisions that were made
in Boca Raton in 1979 are still being
seen in this machine in 2009 so you've
got a whole bunch of parts that are no
longer being made in 2009 you've got the
the the IBM the the intel 8259 are all
these these little parts that are now
being emulated effectively in this
server in 2009 and the it's it's just a
and the only reason we have that is
because it was the microprocessor that
one is because the x86 conquered every
other microprocessor it dragged along
this kind of regretable architecture
with it and now at the same time um
there were a bunch of folks whose
computing needs were really growing very
very substantial and they were beginning
to as they were looking down these
machines they were unimpressed and these
are folks like Google when Todd talked
about Google in the intro by 2009
Google's got very substantial
it needs and it's dawning on Google that
they actually don't want to run personal
computers in their data center they want
to run a more purpose fit machine and
this is kind of their first attempt at
this this is kind of an infamous attempt
at their first machine in that you can
see if they've got velcro so there are
those disks and the power supply are all
secured with velcro the you can see that
it goes a 12-volt battery there in in
lieu of a UPS they actually just had a
12 volt battery attached to every server
this gigabyte motherboard is is the kind
of thing you'd sweep off a floor I mean
no offense a gigabyte but they've gone
with absolutely they have saved they've
shaved everything down to the pennies
here to try to have the cheapest
possible machine on which seems like a
reasonable thing to do like we're buying
a gazillion of these we should make
these as cheap as possible and Google
learned a lesson that has been learned
for time immemorial in computing that is
that um you are but you always want to
seek value but you have to be careful
about unwittingly really getting what
you paid for and when you have
components that are that are DRAM
components that have been refurbed for
example that have that have errors in
them or that are non-ecc I mean on each
CD Ram the the kinds of failures that
you have up the stack aren't worth the
pennies that you saved but they were
onto something they Google and Facebook
and others were onto something in that
they were getting rid of a bunch of
things that they didn't need so you know
wait aren't what you don't see on this
is you don't see the CD drive you don't
see the VGA port you don't see some of
these kind of these personal computer
ephemera and again accoutrements are
being stripped down to have a really a
purpose-built machine um and as time
went on so this is the hyper scale
computing circa 2009 this is kind of
hyper scale computing a mistake circa
2020 this is more like 2016 2017
so this is
a Facebook's Tioga Pass design um so
this is a compute sled this is a compute
sled that goes right into a bus bar so
there's no you know here we had a power
supply power supply is gone here thank
you very very much the power supply is
gone here there's no power supply this
is plugging straight into a bus bar a DC
bus bar there's a power shelf in the
middle of the rack that's doing all the
conversion and when you are at any kind
of modest scale this is a much more
sensible design it makes much more sense
to have a DC bus bar and everybody was
kind of coming to the same conclusion
however the hyper scale which we're all
that people come to for all I add for a
long time which is that power conversion
is really inefficient and the more times
you do power conversion the more you
lose and as you begin to optimize around
PUA
and driving that PUA down it is try to
be as efficient as possible to have all
of your power go to your computing and
none of it going to heating the room or
as little as possible the heating the
room um you are naturally go to these
designs so there are couple
so there's bus there's a bus bar design
that's interesting the the networking
cables are actually in the front for for
accessibility this slides into a wider
chassis so this has got three across
instead of two across it is not the
19-inch rack the 19-inch rack is a very
historical kind of a number um and this
is going into a rack that is a that it
fits on a floor tile fits in a 24-inch
floor tile but is a wider rack it's a
taller rack I'm it's got that that power
shelf in it and it's designed to be a
this is part of a rack that has true
rack level design face book design their
own switch wedge that goes with this
they've they designed their own storage
chassis Bryce Canyon that goes with us
and all made other designs all made
available in the open so this is this is
the evolution of computing it's kind of
good to see you like we're back on track
so computing is back on track we've got
these modern designs okay we can all
breathe easy well not so fast because
this is in hyper scale computing and
this is great and this is again this box
is a really nice box
um meanwhile this is a server-side
computing circa 2009 and here the grand
reveal server-side computing
circa 2020 again not to pick on HP but
sorry HP so we have gone from let's say
we've gone from a CD drive to a DVD
drive so literally you can I mean you
when you buy these machines today they
have a DVD drive um they've got we've
gone from VGA to HDMI I mean these are
not improvements these are improvements
for a personal computer or for a machine
that is designed to run Windows not a
machine that should be designed to run
in a datacenter this is still a
rack-mounted personal computer and it is
that much more galling that the world
that is operating at any kind of scale
has to actually look at this
almost I mean it's I'm so glad that
Facebook and Google and so on have been
so upfront about their designs butBut it
sharpens the pain for those of us who
don't have the infrastructure privilege
of these folks to know that like
actually there's great innovations we
just can't have them and that's that's
very frustrating it's very frustrating
to me personally so so my personal
history I was at Sun Microsystems for 14
years and then Sun was invaded sadly I
left after the invasion
um the I went to a cloud computing
company and it was there for for ten
years I was bought by Samsung and we
were building out a very large private
cloud effectively and we were doing it
on more or less these kinds of machines
and it's not just these were
aesthetically displeasing it's that
there were real consequences up and down
the stack for running what is
effectively a personal computer so this
brings us to kind of the problem that we
have today there are and I'm in this is
the the our very contrarian thinking I I
actually don't believe that Jeff Bezos
is going to own and operate every
computer on the planet they're a
renegade belief I believe that there are
reasons to own and operate your own
computer
they are often economic reasons I'm
there a lot of reasons there can be risk
management reasons but they're they
often well down to economics on that one
you are running a certain amount of
compute it makes more sense to own it
rather than rent it and we've seen this
from a bunch of different companies at a
bunch of different scales
I'm not least at my former employer so
what we know that these economic reasons
exist but we
got the this bifurcated world and the
bifurcated world is actually even even
worse than it looks like because part of
the reason in that when we look at that
that HP commercial server we look at
this thing part of what it is trying to
do is present
- honestly Windows a personal computer
upon which to run so the part of its not
like the engineer's these companies
believe that this is the right
architecture it's just that they are
confined to their layer of the stack
which is the hardware the machine they
don't own the actual software substrate
that sits on top of it and they they
don't really have the ability to control
that software substrate that's that's
another company usually not just another
organization and meanwhile the people
that do control that software substrate
don't have necessarily any understanding
or desire to control the hardware
substrate so you end up with this this
divide the standoff that has endured now
for a decade plus where you you have
these two effectively technology pools
are entirely isolated from one another
and they operate at cross-purposes I
mean if you are tasked with right now if
you are tasked given a budget and told
to run an elastic compute infrastructure
platform on your own premises you are
stuck gobbling things together you are
stuck and and the the state of the art
is really no better than it was 10 years
ago um you are stuck with personal
computer companies you are stuck the
open source software that's out there is
not really designed to run clouds at any
kind of scale so you are gonna be
designing it you're gonna be integrating
it you're gonna be operating it and most
importantly you are going to be
supporting it and it's extremely
frustrating you can have arbitrary
sophistication and still be very
frustrated by this it's only that was
the case for us um we had had many many
many many problems um one of which was a
pandemic of dim failures and we were
seeing pent up pandemic of uncorrectable
dim failures and the thing that was very
frustrating to us is that we would see
no correctable x' before seeing that
uncorrectable the uncorrectable that
would ultimately panic the box and if
you've been around memory for any length
of time
you know that's not really the way the
world works that you don't in ECC memory
you don't see an uncorrectable generally
out of clear blue sky you generally see
a rising number of correctable errors
and those correctable errors indicate
you've got a problem here we're losing
data here and this can be due to design
defects this can be due to poor dim
training this can be due to other
there's all sorts of things that can
cause this kind of loss of data but
those correctable indicate that that's
happening well the problem is that the
firmware was eating all those
correctable --zz so we in in the
software that we controlled we had no
ability to forecast this was coming and
by the way if we knew known it was
coming we could have taken action on
this and if we could have known that hey
this machine by the way is has seen a
spike in correctable errors there are
things that we can go do to force that
force those dents to retrain or what
have you but without that kind of
insight and trying to get firmware that
would actually properly elevate these
errors into system software was like
trying to get a bill through Congress it
would just felt like you know you go to
again you go to a personal computer
company and ask for a custom firmware
build and they're like why would anyone
running a personal computer want their
own firmware doesn't make any sense like
well I'm not running a personal computer
I'm running a cloud but if that
disconnect was felt very acutely by us
certainly and it's been acutely felt by
many many many people this is not this
is not novel or not unique to us so we
feel you really need a fundamentally new
approach and so we think you need to
take a pretty clean sheet of paper here
and so if you're gonna go design a
computer in 2020 from scratch ish what
would you want um first let's not
actually redesign the microprocessor so
the the microprocessor be it Intel or
AMD or even arm the these are very
sophisticated devices and they
themselves are not are are fit for
enterprise purpose so Intel and AMD and
arm and so on are are fit for the
purpose we want one of those folks that
said there are a bunch of other things
we want to go revisit in particular one
of the things we want is real firmware
out of state
so when you run you know when you run
one of these guys you've got no
knowledge of the firmware that's
actually running on that machine and if
you have an issue where you're required
to take a firmware upgrade our firmware
update you get a BIOS upgrade or what
have you
you've got no idea what's in that um
what you do have if you do a kind of a
modicum of analysis on the binary you
will begin to lose sleep at night very
quickly because you will see things like
URLs like what is a URL doing in my bias
this is the brainstem of my data center
why is there a URL in here I'll try to
get an answer that question I am NOT
that it's like an uncomfortable question
it's you literally can't find anyone who
can answer it it's something they don't
want to answer it necessarily
hello bat - what is it URL doing and
presumably not because your vendor has
been infiltrated by kim jeong-hoon
presumably but you don't actually know
that and you've got no way of knowing
that you've got no way of knowing that
what you're running it is a tested
you've got third parties in there I mean
even when you have companies that wish
to actually provide the source code
they're from where they're from where
isn't even theirs this is one of these
things that's just stunning to me and I
mean no offense to them but how is am I
still running at the brainstem of
humanity the american megatrends
incorporated this is a company that was
around when I was a kid I'm old it has I
mean again it's got a right to exist but
why does an am i bias exist on
industrial grade machines it makes no
sense so you got these third parties
that that aren't gonna make available
their source code you can't actually see
into it um and you can't actually know
what you're running and this becomes
really really really relevant if you saw
the the Bloomberg story in 2018 the fall
of 2018 about the super micro
infiltration or a supply chain
infiltration in Super Micro um the and
it would describe a very sophisticated
attack that the reporter stood by and
there you can speculate about what
actually happened there almost certainly
the story as written was not true even
though I think the reporter believes is
true and that that super micro supply
chain was not actually infiltrated
and there was not a device we don't
believe I no one has produced that put
it that way but you may have had the
same reaction that I certainly had upon
reading that story which is out of
curiosity why would anyone mount this
very sophisticated attack frankly when
you can just walk in through the
firmware most Super Micro bmc's have the
default root password on them many of
them are on the internet they are many
of them are vulnerable to known
vulnerabilities I mean if you really
want to get terrified there's a
vulnerability called USB anywhere um
that found by Rick althought who
described it at the open source firmware
conference last year and as part of this
Rick was looking for BMC s that were on
the Internet he found 77,000 BMC's that
were on the internet that he that could
have been owned and rick is an extremely
responsible person so he made sure to
get it all communicated and so on but
that is actually terrifying and the BMC
by the way is the the base board
management controller this is the
computer within the computer well this
is one of the computers in the commune
there are several computers in the
computers it turns out and this is one
of the computers in the computer this is
the one that is the most troubling and
in some regards because it's a full
functioning machine in there it's
running you boot running Linux and
running proprietary software you can't
see from either a speed Anupa our new
baton and that thing is on the brainstem
that is a bus master that is sitting in
your computer um and by the way you hang
it out on the on the network because
that's what your vendor tells you to do
so this BMC is talking to both your PCI
bus is a PCI bus master and it's talking
to the network and you've got no idea
what's in that software that's
disturbing and troubling um we need to
get the we've got to revisit all this we
need an actual proper hardware root of
trust that can actually attest firmware
and this this kind of BMC outgrowth um
needs to be completely rethought and
slashed and we need to go back to a
service processor what this thing needs
to do is it needs to be able to bounce
the box it needs to be able to give you
a serial line and that's about it there
may be like you encountered on one hand
the other things to you yes you need to
have some fan controlling things in
there what it does not need to do is
provide virtual VGA
or virtual USB it doesn't even
necessarily need a networking stock kind
of depending on how you plumb it up but
we need to get back to a service
processor and away from that this is
kind of horrific ly complicated BMC um
we also need host firmware whose mission
in life should be to hand the CPU off to
the host operating system you host from
where what your job is is is to bring
the host operating system its cup of
coffee and shoot yourself in the head
that should be the role of host Ramon
it's a little graphic I apologize the
the that is the role of host firmware
this idea that firmware should execute
and then somehow stay resident so it can
be called into at arbitrary times to do
arbitrary things is it's this is Doss
that's that's the DOS mentality and
approach and boss robbed me of my
childhood okay I've got a chip much
older about thoughts because I grew up
without memory protection at a time
after memory protection existed and I
just thought computers just kind of
reset randomly um they don't and
shouldn't um and as soon as I found out
about memory protection when I arrived
in college I'm like wait a minute why
didn't I have Unix growing up uh I grew
up in the 80s UNIX was around and of
course so complicated were answers to
that question but we should not have a
Doss mentality we should not be relying
on this kind of unseen firmware that is
load-bearing and and needs to do works
there's a lot to be done on the firmware
side and we talked about the the the BMC
is the computers in the computer there
are actually several computers in the
computer there's one that's even in some
ways more disturbing some ways slightly
less because it's um called the Intel
management engine or the platform
security processor on AMD the PSP the
management engine is an entire operating
system that exists on on the another
computer that exists effectively on the
motherboard and that thing also has
total control over heaven and earth it
runs MINIX and yes there have been
vulnerabilities in it so on a management
engine is still completely proprietary
the PSP is AMD's equivalent of this it
actually at least lives on die makes me
ill slightly less worried about it it's
opposed to the PC age but we need to
visibility into it is a reasonable thing
to be able to understand every
instruction that's executing on your
computer that is a reasonable request we
are not there yet Rex you're a long way
from that but but we think that that's
that's needed for for a new computer um
we also need a true rack scale design so
there have been a couple in the industry
that have attended by Rack scale design
I mean really thinking about the entire
rack taking a bunch of to use and
slapping it into rack is not on a rack
scale design that that is that's just
rack and stacked but this is where we
are actually integrating the top of rack
switch with to integrate our networking
with storage with compute and actually
building these things together so they
are aware of one another we are actually
Co designing them you cannot do this
without software and a bunch of
companies they had one I do want to pick
on them you know an Intel is that had a
lot of rack scale design work for a long
time but they never wanted to have a
software component because software or
someone else's job the problem is that
if you don't have that software
component you cannot deliver a true rack
scale design so we need to take a real
rack scale approach what we're designing
these things together you can't just and
this is where you know interoperability
is great in principle but it is very
corrosive when you want to make an
actual tight integrated design and we
need to not be interoperable with
arbitrary topper rack switches you need
to pull that top rack switch in and then
push that boundary of interoperability
out to the network and clearly you need
to be able to talk to other switches and
so on in the network but we want racks
cosine um we also want to have a dense
form factor so we actually deserve the
kind of density that we see out of the
hyper scalars this is a real challenge
because the the hyper scalars really do
design their data centers basically from
scratch and they do a bunch of things at
the DC level that are very hard for
someone else to emulate so if you and
you can be a have a lot of compute but
it's very hard to get to kind of their
level of scale where you're locating
DC's next to dams and so on so this is a
challenge because we're in the
enterprise in the mainstream enterprise
you're not going to drop
25 kW into Iraq I mean I love to it'd be
great but that's not practical because
that that it's just it's it's too much
draw too much too cool
so you defecate it run the plants are
running an IBM seven or nine or probably
been trashed but we need that said
within the kW budget we have for a rack
which on the order of 10 to 15 kW we
need to get maximal density and need to
look at things like a bus power base
design why why can I not buy a machine
if I'm you know General Electric or I'm
Manoa Beth I'm Barclays if I am General
Motors I can't buy a bus bar based
machine no matter how much compute I'm
operating that seems to be a little bit
ridiculous because it seems to me that
we should be having an eye towards
really efficient operation which is
unnecessary low-power operation by the
way this is a high power operation but
but really targeting efficiency so
there's a lot to be done from from the
hardware and firmware perspective and
then there's a lot to be done from the
software perspective and then this is
really you know I think in terms of the
the the beliefs that we and I have this
is probably the one that is is that the
the deepest in our marrow and this is
where you just you're just not gonna get
the Sun Microsystems out of me
I just believe strongly that a computer
should have hardware and software that
have been Co designed that when you
design things together you yield a
better artifact because you are actually
able to control elements of the design
and you're able to yield a higher
performing artifact but in terms of what
does that software mean what what you
know where do you kind of stop the scope
of that I think in terms of in 2020 the
boundary for the computer is at the API
endpoint to provision a virtual machine
you have to view the the you know if the
if the the boundary in the 70s and 80s
was kind of that that multi-user shell
um it was kind of the the boundary then
the boundary now is much higher up in
the stack where I can hit an API
endpoint provision and provision of a.m.
there's a whole lot of software but
between those API endpoints and the
actual provision is a hypervisor there
are there's a toprock switch there there
is a
computer control playing there's a
storage control plane and then you're
gonna have API endpoints for both
operator developer so a lot of software
to be done in the modern computer but I
think this is what this is what's
required because right now that software
is being cobbled together by the end
user and that that seems unfair and
unjust to me now that said okay that's a
lot of software so we gotta like well
the software onto the machine so well
yes and no because certainly the era of
proprietary infrastructure software is
well and truly over so we you don't want
to you don't want to do bluntly what
Apple does I love the iPhone but the the
inaccessibility and - I love you iPhone
from a user experience perspective but
the inaccessibility from the perspective
actually understanding the system and
being able to modify it actually is a
problem um so the software really needs
to be fully open and completely attested
so you want to build on on the this
tradition of open source software
fortunately a lot of what needs to be
done here
is software that much of if you if you
look at you begin to envision that rack
scale machine a lot of what needs to be
developed is software yes there is
hardware but a lot of the hardware and
the hardware innovations are actually
out there fortunately Facebook
interaction will talk about mid and
there the next slide in terms of how
things are changing but things are
changing such that this is actually an
easier problem so um is this attainable
at all can we do this and they're been
plenty in the industry by the way who
have accepted the status quo and have
just that you know what this is just not
gonna change hopefully this will get
better but it's not gonna change and
honestly um I founded myself among that
number I was very very frustrated by the
this kind of bifurcated state but I was
just kind of hoping it would get better
um and when I kind of went back and
deployed a bunch of new computing like
please let have gotten of course it's
not gotten better because it's so it's
structurally so problematic so um we we
have to be able to do this we have to
solve this problem because one this is
not science right this is engineering we
actually know how to solve all these
problems it's just that we've got this
kind of this this organizational stand
that is preventing them from being
solved but there are reasons to think
that this is attainable first of all
this can be tightly tailored so you
don't need to run importantly running a
computer developing a computer that can
run an arbitrary operating system from
das 6.2 to whatever - to a modern
operating system is a very constrained
problem and if you're gonna run every
operating system Under the Sun or gonna
run every hypervisor and support that
that becomes difficult when you can
tightly tailor things the opportunities
open up by the way with the hyper
scalars do the hyper scalars do not run
arbitrary operating systems on their
bare metal they run their hypervisors on
their bare metal so we can tightly
tailor things and by designing one with
the other you can eliminate false
generalities in both software and in the
hardware so you don't need to say in the
software you don't need to support every
device Under the Sun you can support the
devices that you've actually selected so
that you can make it a smaller
engineering problem by being by being
careful but importantly there are also
some larger trends that actually make
this easier than it has been
historically because historically I
think this is this would be actually
very difficult um there's a couple of
big trends a first is on the on the
hardware side lots of folks folks have
recognized the need for a harbor root of
trust and this is something that um you
know I think we have and I for this and
I think actually that the final point on
this slide I think we actually have
Mianus horriblest of 2018 to thank
inspector and meltdown so Spector in
meltdown were the vulnerabilities in
Intel's CPUs I discovered those on
January 1st 2018 with most of the world
in a hacker news thread where someone
was speculating about some kind of fishy
patches they saw the linux and wondering
if there had actually if there was a
vulnerability here and of course we had
not been a part of any embargo I hadn't
heard anything where a huge Intel
customer at the time I'm thinking like I
hope this is not the case but over the
next couple of days of course we learned
that we were vulnerable to not just
Spectre but
but meltdown and meltdown so for those
who are person we've heard a spectrum
meltdown meltdown in particular it is
really really bad all of these things
are effectively ironically using the the
speculative execution of the
microprocessor to get access to
information you're not supposed to have
and it's ironic because it was that
speculative execution that actually
allowed x86 to get past the memory wall
and best effectively every other
microprocessor out there in fact I was
talking even John masters who was saying
that like hey do you think SPARC would
have any of these issues like no spark
would not have any of these issues
because sparks problem was not
speculative enough I this spark wasn't
smart enough to have these issues
bluntly I mean over smart it's just
pejorative but um the spark didn't
speculate enough so the the presence of
these vulnerabilities deep deep deep
deep deep in the stack highlighted all
of these problems up the stack and
suddenly all these firmware issues that
had been people knew were out there
suddenly you had said this this beacon
to security researchers that this is a
target-rich environment you can become
famous by like gangster famous which is
what all the kind of security researcher
as far as I can tell want to become by
finding these vulnerabilities and some
very very clever people pored over some
very ill-conceived a written software
that was not designed to have that kind
of examination we found vulnerabilities
everywhere and people are now very
concerned about ha the hardware root of
trust and from ran a station this is
great so we've seen it Microsoft
Cerberus is an effort that they're there
they are opening up but more recently in
Google's open Titan so Titan is in fact
in many ways the the best computer that
people don't I think properly
acknowledged is the Chromebook the
Chromebook is actually a really really
impressive machine in a lot of ways the
Chromebook actually solves a lot of
these problems albeit for the personal
computer so it was firmware that was
attested did have a harbor trust alarm
that's Titan um and and allows you to
actually you can load your own firmware
on it in that regard it's in contrast to
the iPhone but when you load your own
firmware
on it then the Chromebook itself knows I
am running foreign firmware and it knows
that to not attach to something
it knows that it can't trust the
software substrate that it's on um so
the they did this with Titan and and the
microprocessors that Titan is kind of a
family of a six Google open Titan is
Google's effort to actually generate an
industry-wide effort now open Titan like
many things that Google does Google did
not open up Titan they are generating a
new effort that is in the open so this
is kind of like a kubernetes versus Borg
if you will but that's great that's
great effort certainly law that um and
tacking into those efforts collaborating
with them and so on makes it easier
we're not by ourselves trying to solve
this problem so that that's a really
interesting development another big
development that I don't think it's
nearly enough attention is the open EDA
movement um so the the grand irony is uh
you know people um it was easier to get
a hardware company funded two decades
ago but hardware has never been easier
than it is today it is the the
developing and you know a historically
the EDA space has been one of the last
bastions of proprietary software and now
you're seeing all sorts of interesting
things out there yo sis chisel spinal HD
all these are HDLs yes verification and
then something I mean this is a very
emerging area something called blue
speck which was actually developed 15
plus years ago at MIT um was
historically a proprietary I would call
a VHDL it to call an HDL does it a
disservice because blue speck is
actually taking things up level in terms
of the abstraction in which you you
define the the FPGA um blue speck is
really interesting this is just open
source like ten days ago two weeks ago
something like that very recently um
really really interesting development um
and we are very engaged I would say in
blue spec so a lot of interesting things
on the FPGA side making it easier and
easier and easier to do one's own FPGA
which of course allows you to do all
sorts of interesting things another
terrific development is that
element of risk 5 so risk 5 is a new
instructor set architecture by Dave
Paterson & Co um if you haven't I really
recommend reading the the risk 5 Atlas
EE they call it where they go through
the instruction set it is a delightful
read because they are so deliberate
about learning from everything in the
history of instruction set design so
trying to do really trying to learn what
was done right and what was not done
right and in the history of instruction
sets that are a lot of like there are a
lot of ideas some good some less so but
we should be able to benefit from that
and risk 5 is is really interesting
because not only has it learned from all
of those things and tried to not
recreate you know and I for every I saw
they have really done a very good job of
looking at what they did right and what
they did wrong and trying to develop
best-of-breed but at the same time this
is all freely available there's no
licensing involved in this whatsoever
so this allows you to have now these
soft course so you can have a license
free soft core as part of an FPGA really
easily this is not hard at all and you
can now have your own software running
on that risk 5 core now is that software
running with megabytes of megabytes of
memory no it's running in a pretty
constrained environment but it allows
you to actually have computational
program ability at very very very low
levels of the stack I in the FPGA so
that's that's really neat um in a really
important development
um and then another thing that's
happening and again I and personally my
read is this is a consequence of
spectrum meltdown is that open firmware
is finally arriving so there was a time
when I felt like open from when I was
never going to happen
um that is to say we would have a closed
legacy bias forever but with spectrum
meltdown and with the new focus on these
vulnerabilities deep in the stack and
thanks to the hyper scalars who really
demand this and are funding it
accordingly and
are working with n microprocessor
vendors to demand open firmware and at
the same time funding efforts themselves
we are now seeing the arrival of open
firmware in fact the the best conference
I attended I think in the last year is
the open source firmware conference
which was just over here at Google and
Facebook which was terrific and reminded
me of a conference back in the day where
you would you know back before the
internet you as I tell the children when
you would go to these conferences
thinking that you were the only person
in the world interested in what was a
very kind of narrow slice of humanity
and you'd walk in and there'd be like
300 kindred spirits and it felt very
empowering and that's what open forum
where it feels like it's a really
terrific community and a lot of fun and
all that is being encouraged by this
thing the Open Compute Project so OCP is
interesting developed by Facebook that
Tioga Pass is an OTP design that I
showed you the originally spearheaded by
Facebook with the actual very explicit
idea of passing these innovations on to
other folks that were not that are not
competitors with Facebook so Facebook
viewed it as honestly a social
responsibility which feels a little
strange because Facebook is that your
facebook I mean it's like becoming that
subvert of democracy felt social
responsibility like okay when did that
disappear um but the but talking to the
folks that led that effort in inside of
Facebook 2010-2011 very earnestly
heartfelt effort to pass on especially
some ladies efficiency gains around
things like the bus card base designs
and so on so that has been um that oh
the Open Compute Project has been
growing over the last couple of years
and you know I you might be if you kind
of tuned into this in 2010 or 11 or 12
or 13 and then you thought well yeah
that kind of faded um it actually has
been kind of quietly building steam and
there's a lot of interesting stuff going
on it's that is where the hyper scalars
are really collaborating and if you want
to know like what's happening inside the
hyper scalars the Open Compute Project
is the place to check it out with a
remarkably candid and transparent about
the kinds of things to building which is
great actually OCP summit it assuming
that the coronavirus doesn't cancel it
which is like a little worried but the
OSP summit is coming up
next week here in San Jose and that's a
conference that I would really recommend
attending if this is something that is
of interest to you because there's
there's a lot that's going on with OCPD
that's interesting so a bunch of
hardware developments that make this
easier um these are components the these
are a long long long way from an
assembled system but they are things
that didn't exist even five years ago so
even five years ago this would be much
harder ten years ago much much harder so
there is reason for optimism from the
harbor perspective and then we get to
the system software perspective on so
even in system software things have
changed a lot um and they've changed at
a couple different port parts of the
stack first of all because open source
has now become the expectation for
infrastructure software um to the point
that it's kind of created its own
problems there's now a whole ecosystem
of startups that are open source
companies trying to figure out how to
actually sell a product to somebody and
they're kind of going through you know
their own kind of midlife crisis as they
try to figure out how one actually
monetizes open sources own problem but
an artifact of that is that we've got a
lot of software that is open source and
they're me it's very easy to kind of
complain about things that don't work
but there's actually a lot of stuff it's
an open source that does work that
actually is production grade that
actually is running at data center scale
and we see that I mean I would look at
like just the databases if you look at
what open source databases now versus
open source databases a decade ago or
open source consensus systems now versus
a decade ago
there is absolutely no comparison a
decade ago you were running zookeeper
for consensus and that was it and
zookeeper is not fun um even if you love
zookeeper you will acknowledge that it
is not fun in fact a zookeeper is very
complicated software to get working
there are now lots and lots of consensus
based systems that are out there that
are open source data for databases there
are lots and lots of open source
database systems that that one can go
build a system on and and that I even in
the last couple of years though those
have been developed so that that's all
that much more stuff kind of in the in
the tool
the open operating systems are clearly
all open source I mean there's they're
effectively no proprietary operating
systems left and virtually no
proprietary databases left hopefully we
will get vanquished the last of the
proprietary databases in my lifetime
um but the so I think the biggest
surprise and the thing that if you were
to kind of if I were to go back to you
know go back a decade to to myself in a
time machine and I were to tell my
decade ago self there'll be there'll be
open source databases okay that makes
sense and there'll be there will be open
source consensus based systems that make
sense
there will also be a very important
development in programming languages I
think my past self would have decked my
future self I think my past self would
have tried to take a swing at my future
self because I'm a systems person I do I
view programming language have viewed
programming languages as as part of
getting a job done very pragmatically
and yes I went through you know a
youthful phase of operator overloading
and so on but you you grow out of that
like you you and if you're you know
youth among you who are in that phase
don't worry it'll pass you'll grow out
of it um because you'll realize that
some of the neat things you should you
can do in languages doesn't mean you
should do them certainly not in deployed
systems and especially debugging the
code of others will help a great deal in
this regard if you're wondering how I
can actually help accelerate this
process go to bug the code of others um
and you know I talked about das robbing
me of my childhood I think I say C++
robbed me of my young adulthood for much
the same reasons and I had my love
affair oc+ boss and then vowed to never
go back to it so for me and things like
go are interesting and Java is fine but
um I don't want garbage collection
anywhere near the systems that I'm
developing uh and it's that's not a
pejorative I mean garbage collection is
important and I it's important for for
maybe even most of the world's software
but for the software that that I write I
need too much determinism to allow for a
whistle to be blown that I can't see or
hear my software to be stopped and for
something to go scurrying around doing
something that I can't see with that I
have no control over
that's what garbage collection
effectively is and
garbage collection the the real problem
with garbage collection and I don't want
to I don't want to bag too much of
garbage collection but the problem is
garbage collection is it becomes most
problematic not on sunny days but on
stormy ones so the when garbage
collection is a problem it's because
your actual legitimate heap has grown
large because you are under a height you
have a high degree of work you have a
surging amount of work well garbage
collection now is especially if I mean
god forbid you have no garbage god
forbid that the heap that you have is
actually been as part of a very
carefully manicured program whereby when
you when you are using memory you are
actually using it because then your
garbage collector is actually a heap
scanner and it is a periodic heap
scanner over which you have no control
um that's a huge problem and I just long
since decided that it's like garbage
collection like free to be you and me
it's just not for me and it's not gonna
be with systems that I develop and
indeed I had resigned myself that like
it's gonna be basically see for the rest
of my life and that's fine I you know I
I I'm a craftsperson
and um there are there are things about
seed that I really love I love the fact
that you are in particular when you
write see you can feel the assembly
underneath you see is you know the set
of see pejoratively that it is portable
a portable assembly but to me that was
never preservative that that to me is
Assistance Program it's like no that's
what I want I want portable assembly
effectively because I want to be able to
control the machine so it was a little
bit surprising to me that there has been
a revolution in programming languages
that is really very much changing the
way I and a lot of people think and
that's rust so if you if you haven't
played with rust or haven't developed in
it you you need to because um I
fervently believe that rust is every bit
as important revolution as see I mean if
you look at see and you look at the
systems that came before it
they they look antediluvian they they
look prehistoric and then see comes
along and suddenly it feels modern
but it ended if see is portable assembly
the problem with see is that it's and
it's not even that
you because I think people make a big
deal by the fact that C is unsafe which
is definitely true and C is definitely
playing with loaded weapons all the time
that's definitely true the real problem
with that it's as always as with life
it's like it's not you it's always the
other person that's the problem and
we've see it's not the code that you
write it's the library that you want to
go linked to see composes very very
poorly even in a world where everyone
understands how to write correct C which
by the way I have very reluctantly now
realize after having done a lot of rust
or decent matter I said enough rust
anyway um the idea of correct C itself
has so many asterisks on it because
there's so much undefined behavior in C
I you know this was hit home for me when
I I had a body of software that I wrote
in with 2000 said that became pretty
ubiquitous or a lot of machines called
DTrace allows you to dynamically with
the system there have been there been
very few problems with the choice but
there have been two vulnerabilities in
DTrace over the in the decade and a half
since I wrote it um the or two
vulnerabilities from me person has been
a third but I think that was Adam one of
my the people I wrote it with um but the
two vulnerabilities that I introduced
were both do to effectively malicious
integer overflow where I was doing a I
was comparing a bounds incorrectly which
is very easy to do and see you're you
are you are doing a bounds check that is
correct from the perspective of like
this the software works but it won't
work with malicious input and with
malicious input it can be used to read
arbitrary memory and with our end and
you begin to string that together with
other things and suddenly you have a an
escalation and you're able that's quite
privileged so that was a real wake up to
me rust is not just memory safe its
integer safe
so there are rust is very there's a
bunch of things interesting about rust
one is that it gives you the the power
of that composability because of the
contracts that puts around memory so
russ has the system of ownership
and rust the compiler keeps track of who
owns what and what that actually means
is that it can statically make
determinations about whether things can
be done or not and what what that means
is that when it's made that
determination statically it knows that
this is safe it can now generate a
binary that doesn't need garbage
collection that is actually very very
fast and so the thing that they you know
when the kind of the really the light
went on wouldn't even start to rust is
playing around with it for a small
system and I as one does if you if you
haven't waited into rust you definitely
want to sit down and learn it if you try
to dabble with it it will punish you
because the the model is different but
if you're a C programmer like I am there
is a level which it feels intuitive you
would see you could feel the annoying
assembly where the rust you can feel the
underlying see you understand why the
compiler is complaining when if you
don't understand memory you'll be very
disoriented by rust because it will be
complaining and the tears will just be
streaming down your cheeks these are
often streaming down your cheeks no
matter what because there are times when
rust can be very up in your grill about
things that can be very legitimate
issues that are very frustrating rust
kind of shifts that cognitive load to
when you're actually developing the
software um but the thing that was
interesting to me is I finally kind of I
went through all the phases of greed
with rust was finally bargaining with it
and I just wanted to get this thing to
compile and I didn't care how I did it
and I'm like I just need to do this I I
was trying to do it a clever way I
decided that I was nowhere near clever
enough to do something clever and rust
and I actually needed to do it the
dumbest way possible just to get the
same to compile which I did and like
okay fine now it works now I'm hoping
that this thing is within 20% of my safe
I'd written this thing and see and we
can rerun in rust on and I ran it and it
was like 35% faster than my safe it's
like no I and I got to tell you like
actually it was like not good news I
felt like I took pride in that see like
that was well-written see okay so like
it was not so ignorant you're not
supposed to be performed that well it's
kind of like when you get beat by your
kids and some you know your kids beat
you in basketball or whatever it's like
look kid you're not supposed to let dad
dunk on you it's I mean
you're proud but also like angry and so
it was great that the rust is
outperforming the sea but I was also a
little bit upset I took it apart why I
was outperforming it and when looking at
the memory behavior was much much better
and I was talking to Steve cloud Nick
who's in in rust and I'm like Steve you
know it's amazing that the optimizations
that you've pulled and clearly that
compiler knows so much about heaven and
earth that it is able to truly solve the
memory disambiguation problem because
this and seems like no it's it's true
that that's all possible we haven't done
any of that yet I'm like oh then wait a
minute what so actually the RUS compiler
was not being exceedingly clever what
was happening is that it's rust itself
that's clever because I was using the
only data structure there is no balanced
binary tree data structure to use and
rust you always use a b-tree because
that's the data structure you use well
beech trees it turns out is actually a
better data structure than a balanced
binary tree a beech tree is also gnarly
to implement and a B tree in C is really
gnarly to implement and a B tree is to
implement a b-tree as a library is
extraordinarily gnarly because a B tree
is going to be relocating things
frequently as it rebalances the tree you
actually you're gonna transplant things
unlike with the balanced binary tree
where you're just gonna move pointers
around you're not gonna do some ooh
pointers run you're actually gonna
transit things and the second you do
that you need to have a real contract
with whomever is using that library
about who's gonna do what when so the
point was like you right there are not
really good B tree libraries and say I
mean like take me up on this challenge
go look for a good B tree library and
say it is really really really hard to
implement because the the unsafety of C
makes hard to express that contract with
the library user hard to the point of
being damn near impossible with rust
this is actually really easy because
Russ knows who owns what when and you
are able you are forced to use very
efficient data structures and by being
foresees efficient data structures you
know these artifacts that are
high-performing okay so it's
high-performing but okay where can you
actually use rust the thing is super
interesting about rust ways to me and
this is a new in the last year and a
half is rusts ability to get small
so you can actually you know on these
risk five cores on an FPGA you know you
might have
we've got 512 K of memory um you know
and I was actually with another engineer
of ours who's done a lot of embedded
rust work and um you know I was joking
about the famous thing that Bill Gates
actually never said but is subscribe to
him of 640k ought to be enough everybody
um and we kind of joke about that
because obviously turn 40k is not enough
for anything it's like well actually no
no that's not true
640 K is actually a lot of memory it
actually is and you actually can do a
lot with 640k
especially if you are careful about the
way you spend it and rust allows you to
slim things way way down be a borderline
beyond what you can do with C with C you
can get things very slim um with with
rust you can get things really as slim
it's really remarkable but you still
have these very rich abstractions so
really interesting development and I
engine development in programming
languages for those of us that are
actually building systems and um it's
the name of the company indeed is is a
tip of a hat to rust because we we see a
lot of promise and rust and there are
some really interesting rust a systems
like talk talk is a rough space operates
as actually we're trying to alt here at
Stanford by Phil Elvis and Levy and Co
that are are really interesting that
that we're really fascinated by so you
kind of add all this up and there's a
possibility we think that that this is
something that actually can be built so
this is what we've done we have in we've
started the oxide computer company we
raised seed capital at the end of 2019
if you if you want my happy to give my
war stories on what it's like to raise a
hardtack seed these days which is a it's
it's not even a hot and cold experience
it is both very very frustrating and
very energizing because when you find
the right folks
it can be very energizing but you find a
lot of them not right folks that's
that's not less energizing but we were
able to raise enough money where we give
ourselves a shot
that financed enclosed the end of 2019
and we're ramping the team now I think
we've got 15 folks now going for a fully
functional prototype in 2021 and systems
themselves in 2022
um and we're I mean obligatory if you're
if there's something it interests you
we'll definitely check us out we're
definitely out there and we've got a
long way to go I mean I want to
accurately represent where we are we
really have just gotten started on this
path and we are it is really only in the
last honestly couple of weeks that the
last you know eight weeks or so but even
then we have already seen that there is
a lot of promising direction to be had
so this is a very ambitious problem it's
very hard there are lots of companies
that have tried this and have not
succeeded I'm happy to go through those
at length if you're curious because I
feel like I've collected all of those
the maybe even to a fault actually
uh-huh when we were doing our raise we I
really wanted to learn from every single
person's experience and as a result I
had an appendix slide on every single
company you could possibly name that
looked anything like a computer company
in the last 15 years and the end the
slides were we talked about you know the
company and what happened and so on and
and then we would be able to go straight
to those appendix slides so someone
named a company could immediately go to
the side and point out and it I think it
may have gotten a couple because we were
then kind of viscerally reminding people
of all of these like dead companies it's
probably like not a good idea to parade
a bunch of dead companies in front of an
investor who was like what all you think
about is like dead companies it's like
well no it's important to learn from all
these it's like this is a good idea to
invest in or not so we may have overshot
the mark on that it was a moment where
an investor mentioned each enter ups
great because so first person to mention
degenerate I had an e generous slide
that it's been a long time preparing so
I'm like okay uh just go to slide you
know 102 she pulls up the agenor slide
oh wow
God they raised a lot of money oh wow oh
god that was a zero no no no they're
still alive in the oven and I'm like
wait a minute why are we talking
shouldn't
talking about companies that have
written alright so anyway would probably
overshot the mark on that but
nonetheless we prevailed we raised and
and we're going so very exciting the
other thing the one thing I would kind
of close on one of the things that we
wanted to do and then I'll open it up
for questions and happy to kind of go in
arbitrary directions for folks but one
of the things that that we wanted to do
as part of starting a company I felt we
feel my co-founders steve talk and
jasper sell
we've spent our careers at the hardware
software interface and i feel that too
that some of that lore is being lost if
you will so we wanted to start what we
thought was a kind of a missing
conversation and it started a podcast on
the metal where we have had
conversations with folks at the hardware
software interface and actually just had
a recording today that i'm very excited
to get out there it was really a
terrific recording with star simpson if
you know her really amazing but we have
had a bunch of really interesting
conversations and with stories from from
across the spectrum from across the ages
to to just recent a cross kind of all
ages and and and dispositions and so on
but definitely check that one out so
check out on the metals is that podcast
and with that i will gladly take any
questions yes
yep
by HP yeah the this is the second time
the convex has come up a conversation
this week actually so they drew the
daddy computer companies into the
concrete oh my goodness so those you are
online or chemists are you here to the
convex computer company based in Dallas
I think and they had apparently a
cemetery for AI well as the competition
is one thing uh yeah I mean you can
definitely the competition thing on it
it's it's more interesting I think to
keep track of your ancestors than your
competition because I think they've got
more to teach you then then you're then
I mean it's easy to kind of disparage
your competition we never listen to that
but the it's the folks that seemed like
they were the right place to the right
time and and with the right technology
and didn't succeed that aren't some ways
more intriguing
well let's get the videotape in 1990
yeah right we went to MIT a couple
object is too soon probably yeah right
right yeah yeah I mean that's a very
different era - right I mean that you're
looking at a very very different era
where you are I mean some of those are
microprocessor based companies some of
them aren't your discrete logic you mean
you got a whole bunch of other things in
the mix yeah multi I do not have a slide
on multi flow or convex so yeah that's
great question the the target market is
those folks that are running compute
on-premises so they are and they kind of
come in to a couple different flavors
they are the folks that are running on
premises for good reasons which they are
there are actually good reasons to run
on premises and these folks have been
told that they're basically there are no
good reasons and everything should be in
the cloud and if you and you might be
one of these but if you talk to these
customers they tend to be pretty
animated because they're being told they
don't exist or to the degree they exist
it's like they exist because they're
dummies who don't understand the cloud
it's like no I understand a cloud I'm
not a dummy
I've been on the cloud I understand all
that I've got a regulatory issue or I
have got an AWS bill that will capsize
the company I've got a the cogs of cloud
and if you talked and there are lots of
different people in lots of different
domains and the thing that we see and we
lived this so we we know that this is
coming is that the clouds expensive I
mean the cloud is it's very artfully
priced in that it goes from free
effectively like I don't care I've got
cloud credits or like I don't even know
what the cloud bill is I mean I just
don't care - oh my god this is crushing
me seemingly overnight like that there's
seemingly no time we're like wow okay
I'm kind of groaning but all right it's
just like instantly you go from and and
by the time you really figure out we are
being debilitated by alas
compute prices it's very hard to do
something about it or can't be hard to
do something no there and there been a
lot of companies that have been
vacillating in in part because it is so
hard right now to go on Prem there are
companies that like God we're like we're
being killed but we want to go on Prem
but we don't have the expertise or this
is just too much of a mess or we've
tried we or what we see increasingly as
we stood up some racks and it was a
disaster
um and for all the reasons that we
understand so they we know that that
market exists and we in part because
like not only are they exist but like
they're ornery
I mean they've been like you know not
only are they don't have a roof on their
head but it's been like raining recently
like a cold rain and then if they're
pissed um and actually was anyone here
talking this because I'm agile is part
of raising Aranda you know investors
want to like talk to prospective
customers and we got to the point where
we had customers who and we were very
worried about being very mindful of
those folks and God blessed them and you
know who you are out there who are who
are so excited about this they've been
willing to go through this journey with
us and in particular have been willing
to talk to investors um but we were like
oh gosh you know I hope or being like
respectful your time you know know like
I like bring the VCS to me like I want
to explain to them that I exist and so
we have these Cesar been talking our
customers they almost we're like
shell-shocked they come back with a
comes back okay well you're you're right
you you got some customers that are spun
up it's like ya know they're angry like
I hope you didn't um they don't exist
because they get very very upset if you
tell them that they don't exist so we
know that the market is out there we
know it very much exists and we think it
is today it's those folks that have been
left for dead on Prem but tomorrow and
in the coming decades we believe it'll
be those folks that are born on the
cloud and move on Prem primarily for
economic reasons yes
yeah so in Intel actually I Intel is
actually fine I actually don't have a
problem with until I the Intel Intel's
only I the only thing I wish Intel had
decided to become a computer company a
long time ago instead of respeaking
microprocessor company but I didn't want
to compete with its own channel ah
Microsoft I don't use any Microsoft
products and haven't fir ever since go
gates robbed me of my childhood I'd not
use Microsoft products so Microsoft is
kind of a non-factor here on but for in
terms of microprocessors is the right
good question during the question is
what about arm what about risk 5 ah risk
5 is is is great risk 5 is nowhere near
ready to run modern heavy duty workloads
what risk 5 is perfect for is these kind
of embedded use cases it's great and
where you need that kind of that soft
core even a hard core where you want to
really reason about it but you don't
need an actually high-performing core at
the at the boundary of process so if you
need a 7 enemy I don't think you can get
a 7 a to me I don't know what makes a 7
enemy to risk 5 core but if you um if
you need to be if you want maximal
density maximal performance right now it
needs to be right now it's AMD or Intel
or or arm and like the graviton 2 is
really interesting AWS on the ares core
arm is ion or arm i arm feels very
lateral from x86 um especially AMD right
now is I mean I don't know that I buy a
performance argument and I don't
normally buy a power organ I only know
what problem I would be solving with arm
but that's not I mean no nothing against
arm and personally and maybe I'm just a
victim of the last worse I thought the
ISO wore before and I really don't want
to fight it again I have long since
accepted that it's gonna be x86 from a
nice uh perspective at least for these
kind of virtualized workloads so for
Austin's x86 but everything else we
basically put on the table yes
yeah so the questions how you how do you
evaluate whether you want to be a kind
of one or the other on Prem or on the
cloud um you you'll you know um if
you're in this economic use case you
definitely know and you should be
everyone to be on the cloud clouds great
in fact we talked some people rocked oh
I love the fact that you're like an anti
cloud play like no no no no not anti
cloud not anti cloud at all very Pro
cloud Elastic Compute makes a lot of
sense for most things anyone starting
anything should always start on the
cloud that said you should start on the
cloud knowing that depending on what
you're doing you may get to a scale
where you do need to evaluate going on
Prem and generally you know generally
it's when you're getting ready to file
your s-1 and you are going from a you
know you are a growth funded SAS company
and now you actually want to become a
public company and now actually you care
about margin and when you start to view
the cloud as cogs now it's probably time
to start thinking about being on your
own physical machine at the scale we're
talking about there are other reasons to
be on your own device for kind of you
know personal more personal reasons but
at the scale we're talking about it's
it's a skin problem that's documented
yeah yeah yes
yes yeah so questions like it does Russ
get you the cost of the hardware
absolutely yeah
actually in a way that is way more
coherent than with C because with C
actually it is really tricky to mix C an
assembly in in like you've got a C
program like an operating system has a
bunch of components that are an assembly
and intermixing that with C um you're
kind of in like the compilers in like
best of luck land and it kind of like
can do arbitrary things it's very hard
to kind of intermix those things and
with the profs to I mean your posture
also still a little bit best of luck
land but it is easier to actually
commingle I have found assembly with
with the higher-level language in Russ
ironically but Russ has got all sorts of
support that actually makes it easier so
you've got ways of so I mean that's you
know kind of a silly example but one of
the things that's important is um you
have got the ability to indicate that a
function should have no preamble should
have basically like I want to be out of
ABI land in this function it's like why
would you want to do that it's like well
trust me they're not lightly right it's
not something you do it's something you
do because you you have to do it for a
so for a body of software that may be
very constrained about how it operates
to the point that yeah I can't even save
a stack pointer I can't even do whatever
my ABI preamble is I can't safely do
that in this context and there's a way
to indicate that in rust like this is
this should be a effectively a naked
function and so there are lots of things
like that and with the rise of of rust
in embedded software where I think I
think rust just I think risk 5 will take
over the earth first with the embedded
software I think you can make a case for
Russ to taking over embedded software
almost first which is kind of crazy cuz
it's like it's got a lot of energy and
momentum and other parts of the stack
but it is so far in a way better than c4
that embedded use case and embedded
software has historically been really
really hard to write and get right um
that I think those it's it's an actor I
really recommend there's a series of
blog entries learning rust the dangerous
way
by gonna move Biffle who actually now
works at oxide but cliff has a really
great writing on using rust in these
embedded contexts and you can see the
tricks that he pulls and it would the
tricks that he's able the poll to make
high-performing rust and rust that's on
the metal it's really interesting stuff
yes the C integer overflow oh is it that
if you you just need to make sure that
you're writing your bounds check in a
way that it doesn't actually overflow so
you need to eat you should be very
careful when you're doing unsigned
arithmetic and see in terms of the way
you actually structure the expression
and lint won't help you out at all and
the words in rust you will actually be
told like you can't do this like this
overflows that's right that's right um
sure at some level a bad coding I guess
but it's like the Minette is really
really really hard to get right that the
existing tooling does not help you get
right like again to me like lint where
are you if lint does not warn you about
it I mean certain degrees like okay like
this is my fault
but like hey went like this is the
reason we run lint too and the reality
is it's really really hard for lint to
Prato lint would be we would generate
too many false positives was the reason
that Linda's warning about that
conditioner and people would ever use
them because we've never shut up
whereas rust is much more constrained
about about the way you're able to use
rust is not going to allow you Trent to
transparently mix signed and unsigned
types and so on yes
yeah none of the application no no but
but where's what come from I know in
terms of the apps that with that well I
mean those come from whomever you mean
there are lots of applications in the
universe obviously but if you know if
you've got like a just a you know it's
an example of a customer that is
prominently going back on premise uber
they've talked about this publicly where
over is is now running on on premises
and so they've got a bunch of software
that they've written it that's right yep
that's right
yes yeah not running Oracle yeah um so
yeah so this is where so um it is very
complicated to make high speed
interfaces I mean this is not my domain
of expertise so let's just like let's
just do the big kind of like a caution
here but it is um because you can go
it's a picot inch right you can go an
inch to a picosecond
and the different traces that you take
will have to take different lengths of
time and at the speeds at which ddr4
ddr3 to your and coming to your five
I'll operate all those different trace
lengths have totally different
manifestations in terms of so you have
to have effectively different timing
depending on your trace and dim train
and then environmental conditions about
other things and dim training is
effectively the memory controller
figuring out how to tune itself to get
from a CPU to memory whatever it is it
these interfaces are very fast and it's
so dim training right well in a vacuum
right so they in cooperative things a
lot slower but um
they don't said the DIMM training is
about figuring out and about and when
you receipt Adam for example it will
retrain and that takes time it takes
time to actually figure out what those
kind of constants are and that's very
proprietary kind of stuff I longer than
that and is yeah this is it you're out
of my domain of expertise but it is long
enough that it's not something you want
to do when you if you do if you can
avoid it yes so we I mean it will know
the the the actual the memory controller
will know what dim is in that slot so it
knows something about that dim and if
you change dim if you were receded well
yeah if you to recede it when when the
power was off I guess it would net
wouldn't necessarily know but there are
certainly ways to get the the dim to
retrain if you were to if you were to
change the slot for example that then
when we trained but this on scenes of an
area and system moved not an historic we
had a lot of visibility yes what's not
easy but yes yeah that's true in the
questions like what about all these
other services and there are a bunch of
services and there was a time when
people believed they were gonna consume
any service that any cloud provider put
in front of them
right but if you right so they're in I
mean you can view part of the energy of
kubernetes is about taking that control
back from the cloud providers so people
just don't want to have to have a
dependency on redshift or what-have-you
right maybe they actually are so you
know yes that's true to a degree that's
actually less true than it was five
years ago am I in my view in my view
people are really trying to pare down
their dependencies to easy to EBS s3 and
there are a logical go find another
clouds with the idea being if you give
me a say if you if you give me those
services I can hydrate things up the
stack but I don't want to actually build
something out that's dependent upon RDS
or depending upon you know sqs or
what-have-you
yeah yeah there are like even Suns got
their f1 thing right that is you can so
that they those do exist
i I we don't use them because we're
actually just doing an FPGA like the
old-school way on what it would like a
programmer and an FPGA it's sitting in
front of you but those things do exist
in there they can be useful for certain
applications it's my understanding yeah
uh we're not depending on anybody to
deliver here in terms of these trends so
the these are things that are already
out there so like we're definitely I
mean it's it's easy
yeah like rust is definitely
production-grade and and and is is
usable a lot of the software's is is
either proximities nor something we will
extend you know things like blue speck
are open source and chiselin spinal dl
are out there the risk five is
definitely out there you can build on
risk live today so the the the and then
meet a certain other these trends that
we are encouraging obviously we want to
see and want to collaborate without this
but I would say there's these are things
that are all happening kind of
independent of what we're doing but
things that we are certainly a part of
and artisan absolutely yeah yeah all
right thank you very much